What cures in therapy is truth.
That's the curative.
Now there's exposure to the things
you're afraid of and avoiding as well,
but I would say that's a form of enacted
truth because if you know there's
something you should do by your own set
of rules and you're avoiding it,
then you're enacting a lot.
You know you're not telling one,
but you're acting went out.
It's the same damn thing.
So if I can get you to face what it is
that you're confronting that you know
you shouldn't be avoiding,
then what's happening is that we're both
partaking in the process of attempting
to act out your deepest truth and what
happens is that that improves people's
lives and it improves some radically and
the evidence,
the clinical evidence for that is
overwhelming.
We know that if you expose people to the
things they're afraid of but that
they're avoiding,
they get better and you have to do it
carefully and cautiously and with their
own participation and all of that,
but of all the things that clinicians
have established that's credible,
that's number one,
and that's nested inside this deeper
realization that the clinical experience
is redemptive,
let's say,
because it is designed to address
suffering in so far as the people who
are engaged in the process are both
telling each other the truth and then
you think,
well obviously,
because if you have some problems and
you come to talk to me about them,
well first of all just by coming to talk
to me about them.
You've admitted that they exist.
Man.
That's a pretty good start in second.
Well,
if you tell me about them,
then we know what they are and then if
we know what they are,
we can maybe start to lay out some
solutions and then you can go act out
the solutions and see if they work.
But if you don't admit they're there and
you won't tell me what they are.
And I don't,
and I'm like posturing and acting
egotistically and taking the upper hand
in all of that in our discussions.
Well,
how the hell is that going to work?
You know,
it might be comfortable moment to moment
while we stay encapsulated in our
delusion,
but it's not going to work.
So a lot of that seems to think it
through.
It seems pretty self evident.
And you know,
Freud thought that repression was at the
heart of much mental suffering.
The difference between repression and
deception is matter of degree and that's
all.
It's technical.
It's a technical differentiation.
And Alfred Adler who was one of Freud's
greatest associates,
let's say,
and much underappreciated,
I would say he thought that people got
into problems because they started to
act out a life lie.
That's what he called it,
a life lie that's worth looking up
because Adler,
although not as charismatic as Freud,
was very practical and,
and really foreshadowed lot of later
developments and cybernetic theory and
of course young believed that you could
bypass psychotherapy entirely by merely
making a proper moral effort in your own
life.
And Carl Rogers believed that.
It was honest communication mediated
through dialogue that had redemptive
consequences and the behaviors believe
that you do a careful micro analysis of
the problems that are laid before you
would help introduce people to what
they're avoiding.
It's like all of those things to me are
just secular variations of the notion
that truth will set you free
essentially.